وتحت تساقط الامطار الغزير في هذه المنطقه
التي تاوي عشرات الالاف من النازحين
الفلسطينيين غمرت مياه الامطار هذه
المنطقه التي تاوي مخيمات النازحين في هذه
الاوقات الصعبه الذي يعيشها النازحون
الفلسطينيون في منطقه غرب مدينه دير البلح
حيث تساقط الامطار الغزير والرياح تطايرت
اعداد كبيره من خيام النازحين هنا في هذه
المنطقه بعد ان غمرتها مياه الامطار التي
سقطت في هذه المنطقه وايضا غرقت اعداد
كبيره من خيام النازحين الفلسطينيين هنا
اوضاع صعبه جدا والله عمنا ما احنا عارفين
نقعد ونتفه الغض مش عارفين نقعد نتغدى كنت
نفسه مش عارفين نيمها لا عارفين نلبس
الولد ولا عارفين ننيم البنت الصغيره ايش
هالحال هذه يا ابن مولود يا خال عمره يوم
امبارح طلع من مي فوقيه مش عارفين شو يسوي
والله ما احنا عارفين اطلع النم تعال شوف
اطلع اطلع الميه خشت علينا واحنا اطلع الم
قرب قرب
نفسه حطيت لها بوكس عشان تنام
[تصفيق]
عليهم
[موسيقى]
شايف حياتنا
مرت اشرف ابو
عمير
[موسيقى]
هتغرق الخيمه جوزي قاعد بدور على مكان مش
عارفين وين بدنا نروح وين ما نروح مش
عارفين ندور على اي مكان ماحدش راضي فيش
وسع مش عارفه وين بدنا نروح احنا هقيت جا
قاعد بدور على مكان لفلف له من السته
الفجر والله من امبارح منام و بدور على
مكان هنا ادنى مقومات الح لا توجد في هذا
المخيم البسيط والتي غمرته مياه الامطار
غرب مدينه دير البلح يتجمع عشرات الالاف
من الفلسطينيون النازحون في هذه المنطقه
التي تاوي هذه المخيمات البسيطه في غرب
مدينه دير البلح رغم كل الظروف القاسيه
التي يعيشونها في هذه
الاوقات شايف كيف شايف كيف اواعيها مبهدله
شايف غيارات ه طفله بدها تغير بدها مكان
داف معها كحه ومعها رشح وم عارفه اجيب لها
دواء من لخير يشنا كله مي يشنا كله مي
بتبهدل اولادنا اعيه
بتنشف والله ناموا والله العظيم ناموا
وعيهم
[موسيقى]
مي
رغم تساقط الامطار المستمره والغزير هنا
وغرق عدد كبير من خيام النازحين الا ان
اعداد كبيره من النازحين مازالت متواجده
داخل خيامها رغم الظروف الانسانيه الصعبه
للغايه هنا غرب مدينه دير البلح اشرف ابو
عمره لقناه الجزيره دير البلح وسط قطاع
غزه